[ __ ] crawls through a
dark ventilation duct.  He arrives at a
secret command room, red lights, monkeys with
headsets looking at giant screens.
[ __ ] takes out a bananaphone and records the scene.
Below, Monjefe points to a map of the
entire jungle.  He says, "Platanael is going to dominate the
world economy." [ __ ] is surprised, and
Platanófono falls to the ground. Monkey guards
are alerted and see Monkey hiding behind a
ventilation grate. [ __ ] runs,
but the guards catch him and lock him in the
Dark Room. [ __ ] wants to understand
exactly what he saw, how such a small jungle
can dominate the world economy, what
Platanael has done to acquire the
world's most advanced technology, and what the
ultimate plan is to dominate the
world economy. Today, Monkey explains everything. The paradox
of size. Platanael sounds big, but it
only has 540 billion green leaves in
PIP. That's all. Even Plataña has
more. Economically, Platanael is
minuscule, barely 0.5% of the entire
world economy, as small as the white
banana threads that Monkey doesn't like to eat.
But here's the surprise. 20% of the
jungle economy is high-tech, which sounds
normal, but 50% of all exports
are pure technology. That's called
hyper-concentration. It's Monkey putting
all his bananas in one basket.
Monkey is looking for someone to buy technology from
Platanael. Open its client list, see
big names: Google, Microsoft,
Nvidia, Apple, Amazon, Meta, Intel—the
most powerful companies in the global jungle.
Why do such powerful companies spend
so much green space in a tiny jungle?
Because Platanael has something rare, something
that can't be easily copied: software
that protects the data of larger companies
. Monkey engineers from other
jungles have been trying to
manufacture it for decades, but they can't. Platanael does
n't dominate because of its size; it dominates because without
its technology, machines from large
companies don't work, systems crash,
and larger companies in the global jungle
know they have no other option. Now,
Mono knows that Platanael sells
technology, knows that larger companies
in the global jungle buy it,
but doesn't know why they can't
manufacture it themselves. Because with
all the green space they have, with
all their monkey engineers, they keep
coming to Platanael to buy cyber
jungle. Platanael has 434
research centers belonging to the world's largest companies
in a jungle the size of a banana.
Google has equipment there. Microsoft
too.  Nvidia, Apple, everyone. Not because
they like the weather, but because that's where they find the kind of
brainpower they can't find anywhere
else. But a monkey needs
numbers to truly understand. March
2026. Google buys Wi for 32 billion
green leaves. A Platanael startup. It does
cloud cybersecurity. Biggest acquisition in
Google history. In taxes alone.
Platanael's stock market value exceeds 3 billion
green leaves. But it's not an isolated case.
Nvidia buys Ran AI for 700 million
green leaves. Also a
Platanael artificial intelligence startup.
United banana regulators approve
without hesitation. European regulators too, because they
all know the same thing. Without that software,
their machines perform worse. Platanael doesn't
export bananas, it exports a system that
protects bananas from the rest of the monkeys, it
sells security, it sells that hacking monkeys
can't get where they shouldn't, it sells that everything works
, even if a powerful monkey tries to
break it. Platanael captures 40% of all
private investment in cybersecurity from United bananas
.  40% with fewer than 10
million monkeys inhabiting the country. A monkey
looking at those numbers thinks the same thing as
always: those green leaves aren't
for him, they're for
giant corporations, for monkeys in suits and
briefcases. But XTB allows any
monkey to start investing with
small amounts. XTB is a broker that sponsors
monkey videos and allows investment with
0% commission without requiring 100 documents,
without explanations from a monkey banker who
speaks strangely. Open an account in minutes and
explain things as if the monkey had the
brain of a monkey regulated in banana republics and
all Latin American jungles. So, a monkey from
any jungle can join. The difference
between an investing monkey and a gambling monkey is
simple. A gambling monkey throws green leaves
and hopes for luck. An investing monkey decides
before acting. XTB requires this
with an investment plan. Before investing the
first coin, the monkey chooses where each
green leaf goes, how much risk he accepts, what
happens if the market falls. Plan first,
green leaves later. The monkey can open an account
on XTB via the link in the description and
pinned comment or by scanning the QR code on the
screen. In 2025, startups of  Platanael
has raised over 15 billion
green leaves, 70% of which are dedicated to cybersecurity and
artificial intelligence. This isn't
by chance, nor is it a stroke of luck; they
've spent decades building
precisely this. Platanael understands that if a
large company experiences a
security breach, it could lose absolutely
everything. And this company is prepared to
protect its treasure with millions of
green leaves. 396,000
monkeys work in high-tech in
Platanael, representing 10% of the total population, yet
this 10% pays 25% of all
jungle taxes. These monkeys sustain healthcare,
infrastructure, the military—everything. But
technology is just one aspect, because
while Platanael was building
laboratories, it was also building
something else. And when the jungle erupts into
conflict, when missiles fly, when
everything burns, Platanael is the only jungle that
knows exactly what to do.
Iron monkeys. Platanael has lived in a state of war for decades,
watching missiles from enemy jungles
rain down, but its
defense systems intercept nearly 100% of them
. The entire world.  He sees it on
screens. The result is immediate.
Global demand for air defense
skyrockets like a banana dropped from a
high branch. Germany buys a
hypersonic anti-missile system. 3.5
billion green leaves. The UK
wants it too, as do Italy and the Nordic countries.
Everyone rushes to Platanael. Everyone wants
missile shields. Platanael is the
world's seventh-largest arms exporter.
When the European jungle was rearming itself because of
Ukraine, Platanael became the
supplier no one could refuse. And it's not
just defense; beneath Platanael's waters
lies something else. The Tamar and Leviathan fields.
Gas, tons of gas. The European jungle
had been paying for gas from the wrong jungles for years
, depending on jungles that
could cut off their supply any
morning. Then, Platanael opens the tap. The
European jungle signs an agreement. But
Platanael doesn't just want to control
resources from its jungle; it wants to control
logistics for half the world. Project Imec, a
railway that starts in the Indian jungle,
crosses Arabia, crosses Jordan, and arrives at the
port of Aifa, Platanael's port.
From there, everything continues onward.
European jungle. It would become the
world's most important trade route. That's
called critical infrastructure. So far,
Platanael sounds like a jungle that has
everything under control, but there's a
waterway, so small it's barely visible on a map
. If the passage closes, 20% of the
world's dinosaur juice will be trapped,
changing the game for Platanael.
Ormud in flames. February 2026.
United Bananas and Platanael attack the Iranian jungle.
Supreme leader dies. Terán closes the
Strait of Ormud. That's called an
energy collapse. The strait channels one-fifth
of the world's oil. But not only
that, one-fifth of the world's natural gas also
passes through it. Prices
skyrocket. Brent crude rises from $70 to $110
in days. Monkey analysts warn it
could reach $200. Global inflation
returns. The People's Republic of Bananas
needs oil. So does India. Japan.
South Korea. Imports have to
cross Ormud, but they're trapped. Monkey
thought the crisis was created by Platanael  It
hurts him, but it's the other way around. A crisis
that destroys the world economy strengthens
Platanael. Demand for air defense
rises. Demand for cybersecurity rises.
Demand for alternative routes rises. IMEC is
no longer a theoretical project, it's
survival. The European jungle needs
gas that isn't from the Russian jungle.
Asian jungles need routes that don't pass
through Ormud. Platanael is in both.
Platanael is the solution. Truth isn't
conspiracy, it's a plan. Platanael doesn't
dominate because it's a large jungle, it dominates
because it became indispensable. Because
when the entire jungle goes into crisis,
everyone needs what only Platanael
has. Meanwhile, on a remote beach
in an unknown jungle, waves break
against the sand. [ __ ] opens one eye, then the
other. He sees sky, he sees palm trees, he sees a
half-eaten banana beside him. He doesn't know where he
is, he doesn't know how he got there, he doesn't remember
anything, he only knows one thing. Something big is
approaching, he doesn't know what, he doesn't know when,
but he feels it in his bones. Warren
Moné already warned about it. The jungle has burned
four times and always, always, before
Crisis signs are the same. Watch the
video where Mono reveals the
signs to detect if it's a real crisis or just
smoke and mirrors.